[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much and thank you pat
Provencher this got some more highlights
to talk about now just in case you
haven't been glued to your phone the
last few minutes I want you to hear
something from me a little later than we
anticipated but better late than never
official verified caucus results are
coming in from the state of Iowa they're
not complete but results are in from the
majority of precincts and they show our
campaign in first place
[Applause]
so we don't know all of the numbers but
we know this much a campaign that
started a year ago with four staff
members no name recognition
no money just a big idea a campaign that
some said should have no business even
making this attempt has taken its place
at the front of this race to replace the
current regimen
and no matter what happens next this
much is undeniable that fact represents
an astonishing victory for this campaign
this candidacy and this vision that you
all have been apart this validates the
idea that we can have a message this
same message connect in urban and rural
and suburban communities that we can
reach out to Democrats and to
independents and even to some future
former Republicans ready to bring change
to this country it accommodates the idea
that we can expand a coalition not only
unified around who it is we're against
but around what it is that we're for and
it validates for a kid somewhere in the
community wondering if he belongs or she
belongs where they belong in their own
family then if you believe in yourself
and your country there's a lot backing
up that police
this is what we had been working more
than a year to convince our fellow
Americans
that a new and better vision can bring
about a new and better day and now we
come to New Hampshire a state that
famously thinks for itself and as we
enter this new phase this week ahead to
convince New Hampshire to support this
vision and then go on I have never been
more confident in our campaign in our
team and a division that brought us to
this point it's also never been more
important to gather and muster all of
the support that we can to get the word
out so if you were here as a believer in
the message of this campaign we need
your help more than ever we need you
knocking on doors we need you calling
your friends and if you're watching at
home we need you going to Pete for
america.com to chip in so that we can
keep building this organization that's
going to carry us into the future but I
also know there are some folks here who
are still making up your minds and I'm
here to look you in the eye one more
time and ask you for your support and
explain why I am here for the same folks
who a year ago when we poked our head
into the diners and coffee shops around
here were saying things like okay how do
I say her name again
and then by summer let me know that I
was really getting somewhere by giving
me that that uniquely New Hampshire
compliment of telling me that I was in
your top seven
because and I admire this you take so
seriously that role that influence that
you have as voters in New Hampshire but
now here we are in it's decision time
and even more than usual there is so
much at stake in the decisions about to
be made there is so much at stake
because we cannot go on with the
presidency like this and there is so
much at stake because this is one of
those years we just happen to be alive
and registered to vote in one of those
years that it's going to decide not just
what the next four years are gonna feel
like but what the next four years forty
years they're going to be like we're not
just seeking to win an election we are
seeking to win an era for the values
that we all share so here we are and as
I always do I want to begin by inviting
you to form in your own mind a vision
that guides this campaign an image that
helps us remember what's at stake and
what we've got to do in order to govern
and in order to win and that image that
I want you to visualize is how it's
going to feel that first time that the
Sun comes up over New Hampshire and
Donald Trump is no longer the president
to the United States
I know so many fellow Democrats who have
been working to make that a reality I
have met so many independents who never
felt attached to a particular party but
most certainly don't want to feel
attached to this current White House and
even Republicans who are just tired of
looking their kids in the eye and tried
to explain this presidency to them
unified on the need to bring about that
day and what a good day it will be are
you not ready to put the chaos behind us
want to be nice to put the meanness
Fine's want to be relieved to put the
tweets behind us and yet I raised the
image of that day not just to talk about
what we've got to bring about and what's
got to change but also the work that
will begin on that day to make sure what
will be needed from our next president
in terms of governing think about what
it'll be like think about our cuts
you'll be up against on that day on that
day the economy will be increasingly
shaped as it is now profoundly changed
by technology by gig economy issues
things weren't even thought about just a
few years or decades of government well
meanwhile when it comes to our climate
we're going to be facing climate
challenges that have left left off of
the pages of the science books and into
our lives from coastal communities to
river cities like mine in the Midwest
where once in a century floods are
becoming an annual event this is upon us
and will require new ways of thinking in
order to deal with it quickly and
internationally too we will face
challenges not thought of just a few
years ago not just the kind of
conventional military issues that I
trained on when I was serving but cyber
security threats election security
threats global health security concerns
demanding a new vision and a new
approach all while the next president
takes office in a Washington that has
been torn apart even by the standards of
Washington by partisan division and
political dysfunction that's what's
ahead and I'm not telling you that to
scare you because I believe that we as a
country are up to that task
to remind you about how important it
will be that the next president be ready
to turn the page to lead the politics of
the past in the past and to have a
vision for what comes next
and yet that look to the future that is
what we will need in order to govern in
order to lead that's also what we're
going to need in order to win this
election and we must win this election
so I'm here to tell you you don't have
to choose between the right way to
govern and the best way to win because
winning too requires that view to the
future consider that